bailleurs sociaux acteurs immobiliers et
conseillers municipaux de la verrière
ils étaient tous réunis autour de la
ministre du logement emmanuelle cosse et
lui ont présenté les projets
d'habitation de la commune on voit bien
que sur les questions de financement sur
les questions de montage juridique il ya
encore un travail à faire il ya des
choses qui ont été faites qui améliore
mais il ya encore un travail donc les
investisseurs les promoteurs sont
présents sur le territoire de la
verrière ont pu poser effectivement à la
ministre ces questions pour faciliter
les montages dans ses projets un habitat
participatif rue de la mare 14 logements
devraient voir le jour à cet emplacement
mais le gros projet sait la zac la zone
d'aménagement concerté de gars bécane
des habitations mais aussi un pôle
d'activité de plus de 80 mille mètres
carrés oui c'est important d'aller
soutenir les collectivités qui
s'engagent sur sur ces questions là
parce que quand vous êtes maire d'une
commune de 6000 à 8 ans vous envisagé de
construire
1000 1500 logements c'est une évolution
considérable et il ya aussi un enjeu
d'activités économiques sont très
important de le rappeler qui est qu' il
faut qu'on rapproche l'activité
économique les logements parce qu'on
sait que typiquement notamment pour les
habitants des yvelines
beaucoup d'entre eux travaillent sur
l'arrêt sur le centre de paris ou à la
défense et qu'on a des temps de
transport extrêmement difficiles avec
les 1800 logements prévus sur la zac la
verrière deviendra une commune de près
de 10000 habitants
les travaux devraient débuter en 2017